thank you
might think that jogging has always been
a popular form of exercise but you'd be
wrong idiot joking boss humans have been
running and jogging presumably since we
came down from the trees they can't
point in human history where it was no
longer commonplace it wasn't actually
until the 1960s that a coach called
Arthur Lydia from New Zealand
reintroduced running as a form of
exercise I believe it's jogging or
yogging it might be a soft J at first
people thought it was weird but of
course it caught on and the rest is
history something similar happened with
going to the gym it wasn't really until
Arnold Schwarzenegger and Co popularized
it via films like pumping iron that it
became a really common thing for more
people to do the big three power lifts
are only the big three power lifts
because they're the ones that were
chosen for competition say culturally
specific thing to our current time today
we're seeing more unusual forms of
exercise and training start to gain
popularity so don't rule out other
exercises that are out there even if you
feel a bit strange and people look at
you funny you never know you might just
invent the next jogging and bye for now